Donald Trump took part in a bizarre
public statement alongside the dog that
took part in the raid that led to the
death of Isis leader Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi and every aspect of this
public statement or I guess we would
call it sort of like a conference of
sorts was very very odd now number one
as if we needed more proof that Donald
Trump just doesn't understand dogs in
the video I'm gonna play for you look at
how Trump is just so far from the dog
clearly has no interest in it it's
really a prop like most of the things
and people around Donald Trump it's a
prop for his own purposes but it's even
more noticeable with the dog where
normal people you know who don't have
like a fear of dogs so to speak they
react to dogs in a way that seems human
I guess it's the best way that I would
put it and you'll see here that Donald
Trump calls the dog brilliant and smart
based on him I guess spending time with
the dog but he just can't seem to relate
to the dog in a way that seems normal
take a look it's really and I actually
think Conan knew exactly what was going
on but a dog that is very very special
and we could maybe say
something about the type of dog
and you're going to put a muzzle on the
dog and I thought that was a good idea
but then it gets even more violent so I
had a choice but now the dog is
incredible actually incredibly we spent
some good time with it and so brilliant
so smart yeah just the genius brilliant
dog Trump can obviously tell is this
seeming strange to anybody else
it went on with Trump calling the dog
The Ultimate Fighter and the ultimate
everything in terms of quote sniffing
drugs
I guess Trump means sniffing out drugs
or something like that but also I didn't
think that this dog did that this was a
dog that is a military dog take a look
at this special dogs they're very hard
to get this particular dog is this is
the Ultimate Fighter ultimate everything
ultimate in terms of sniffing drugs we
have we spent a tremendous amount of
money on drug equipment at the border
then I was talking to the people I say
well is there anything better than this
equipment no sir the only thing better
is a dog a dog this type of dog exactly
because it's a certain type of dog right
it's a certain type of dog that Trump
can't identify and knows nothing about
but it's definitely a certain type of
dog one more clip from this very strange
moment and it's pretty amazing but they
are really better we had a case where we
had drugs in a cylinder of a car
and it was undetectable by this very
expensive machine which is really
amazing machinery but still it was
undetectable the dog came in wah jumped
in the hood pointing you know they
opened the hood and knew exactly it's
incredible the sense of smell or
whatever it may be probably sense of
smell so they're incredible animals and
thank you all very much
yeah it was its sense of smell or
something who knows anyway right does
this dog have anything to do with
sniffing drugs at the border as far as I
know this is a military dog that has
nothing to do with that whatsoever it's
like Trump just can't make stuff up and
tell the truth yeah I can't he can't not
make stuff up he can't simply tell the
truth they had to by the way put Mike
Pence in the photo-op touching the dog
because it's very clear Trump doesn't go
anywhere near dogs he has no empathy for
another living being he he even maybe
appears to be afraid of the dog actually
from from what I saw not even going near
it I don't know anything about that the
dog seems to actually be able to sniff
out sociopaths and it is signaling
big-time around Donald Trump seriously
though both Trump and Melania avoided
any contact with the dog during this
entire public appearance and check out
how awkward it is before this when Trump
and Melania come out and announced that
they have Conan the dog there
so this is the content right now
probably the world's most famous dog I
don't think I have to use the word
probably and Conan is a incredible it's
an incredible story I learned a lot
about this particular type of dog could
trump and Melania look any more
uncomfortable and have any more space
between them and the doc this reminded
me of when in June I went to LA and was
on the Joe Rogan program after the show
I took a picture with Joe and a bunch of
people the pictures on my Instagram if
you want to see it a bunch of people
reached out to me and they said David
why are you guys standing so far apart
and when I looked at the picture there
are like maybe six inches between Joe
and I Melania and Trump seemed to be
like 10 feet from this dog that they
claimed to think is just so great and
wonderful and lovely in every way
they just can't even be around a dog in
a normal way and it might be lack of
empathy that prevents Trump from being
around dogs it also could be his known
germophobia who knows but a very strange
moment and I think that this is what
people around Trump imagined helps to
humanize him because he clearly doesn't
relate to people in what we would call a
normal way I think a pretty big failure
but because very obviously not relating
to the dog in a normal way either I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink
komm slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli n ki st.com /pa ke ma n